i think most people would be surprised
at how much information they unknowingly
give away online
and how that can leave them vulnerable
when people like me come along and
collect all of that information
it's incredibly easy to track anyone
with any modern technology now
it's incredibly difficult for anyone to
try and avoid detection
when i went on the run back in the 1990s
there was still just about a chance to
do it because it was very resource
intensive
for either spies or corporations to
track people who went on the run
[Music]
i'm scott helm i'm a cyber security
researcher and an ethical hacker
[Music]
i'm annie mashon i'm a former
intelligence officer with mi5 the uk
domestic security service
[Music]
so i think many people would be very
surprised about what we can find out
about them online
i met someone recently where we
demonstrated this and with just their
name and knowing the general area where
they lived we were able to narrow down
their social media profiles we have
things like the birth
marriages and death register in the uk
where we can look up your marriage
certificate or your birth certificate
from there we can see
parents and spouses and we can start to
spread out this net of information that
we can gather about you from
very simple resources social media over
the last decade has become the spy's
dream
back in the 1990s my job as an
intelligence officer was to build up
profiles
and investigate targets and that could
take weeks trying to get a shape of
someone's life their contacts where they
worked their relationships their views
their activities their hobbies
everything now of course with social
media
we just offer it all up for free
voluntarily i think privacy
has changed so dramatically in the last
10 years if
we go back 10 years it would have been
very difficult to gather information
about someone very
analog very offline we may have to
collect pieces of paper or documents and
now in the digital world it's
a click of a finger and a search on the
internet and we can have a lot of
information about someone
[Music]
social is really easy we can pick up
twitter send a tweet that
you know my internet has stopped working
so i might tweet my internet company or
more recently my water supply stops
working and the water company will have
status updates and people will comment
on them and we now know that all of
these people
are users of this company's services so
you know if i wanted to impersonate them
i could call one of those individuals if
i had their number and say hey
sarah you know i'm from the water
company you know just regarding your
complaint can we go through account
security could you confirm
your postcode for me please and i'm then
extracting more information
using the original tweet as the leverage
to get you to trust me
it's interesting to ask who might be
spying on us i mean obviously
for someone who worked in the
intelligence agencies i think of
espionage and spying and surveillance in
a particular way
where you are given targets to
investigate first of all
yes it might be the law enforcement
intelligence agencies depending on what
you're getting up to
it could be political activism as simple
as that two it
will definitely be the big social media
corporations because we are their
product
and the question is then to
realistically say okay
what might be the threat to me
personally how can i best protect myself
from those threats
you don't have to be on the run from the
government or from mi5 you might just
want a bit of privacy
smartphones are little spy phones in
your pocket turn off your smartphone
ideally leave it at home another really
good thing for people to look at
is the privacy settings on applications
on their smartphones
so maybe you don't want an application
to be able to look through your
photographs you can go into the settings
on your phone and disable these things
so go into your device's settings have a
look through those and just think you
know
this app doesn't need my microphone so
i'm just going to turn that off make
sure it can't listen to me
it doesn't need my location i'm just
going to turn that off as well and just
start to take a little bit more control
over all of the information that you're
sharing
one thing you can do of course is to
invest in older technology get an old
burner phone that you might just use for
phone calls and that's it
use an old laptop and then a whole suite
of privacy software
on that laptop as well another really
great way of protecting yourself if
you're traveling a lot
using public wi-fi an airport or a train
station they commonly ask for your first
name and last name in order to log in
what you can do is give them a different
first name and last name to log in
and you'll still be able to use the
wi-fi network afterwards this may sound
a little paranoid but when i was in
berlin a few years ago at the height of
the snowden disclosures
if you went to parties you were expected
to put your mobile phones in a tin a
biscuit tin
which then went into the fridge to stop
signals going in coming out to stop the
phone
snooping on you i think it's really
important that people make conscious
decisions
about the information that they share
because often when we share this
information you could never guarantee to
be able to take that back
if i send a tweet to a company and you
know i want to make a complaint about
their service
i may be able to delete that tweet later
but everyone's already seen that and
knows that i had that interaction so
making this
conscious decision before i take those
actions
would help me prevent leaking that
information later
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification
each time we upload a new video